there's three things that are most
important to chefs first is flavor
second has flavor and third is flavor
flavor rules built on the Fertile former
lake bottom soil of northern Ohio the
chef's garden is a 300 acre family farm
that grows specialty produce for some of
the world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases we're working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farm grows produce of all shapes and
sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens but the Jones
family wasn't always the chef's garden
my parents have had some very successful
years in 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm and ultimately the
farm collapsed we were dealt a new deck
of cards and found opportunity within a
disaster
we met a European influence chef iris
Balin to grow me varieties for flavor
grow me varieties without chemical I
want a zucchini bloom thought this lady
was absolutely crazy little do we know
she knew a heck of a lot more about it
than we did and that really opened our
eyes to another whole world out there we
hooked up with some really great chefs
early on folks like Danielle Beaulieu
and jean-georges Vongerichten and Alain
Ducasse and Michel Rashard and then
Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter and in
ritz-carlton chefs and for seasoned
chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture
we're indebted to those chefs that have
given us the privilege and the path to
be able to follow our dream of farming
so it's that symbiotic relationship of
chef and farmer working together for the
greater good and here we are 35 years
later still working to get better to the
best of our ability right now in this
place I think we're doing the right
thing and I think that trumps every
other reason for whatever you do in this
life